Traduttore: Lucia Girotti
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Questa è "La Tempesta", uno dei quadri
più importanti della storia dell'arte,
e anche uno dei più misteriosi,
come il suo autore,
il Giorgione
da Castelfranco Veneto.
Artista tanto enigmatico
quanto leggendario
che già in vita diede
una svolta epocale alla pittura.
Quest'opera, per molti storici,
è considerata il punto di non ritorno
l'opera che anticipò i tempi
verso la maniera moderna.
Probabilmente quest'opera è stata dipinta
a poche centinaia di metri da qua.
Vi basti pensare che tra il Quattrocento
e il Cinquecento italiano,
assieme a Leonardo, Michelangelo,
Tiziano, Raffaello,
il Giorgione diede il via a quel progresso
figurativo che ancora oggi spinge
gli artisti di tutto il mondo
alla ricerca della perfezione.
Facciamo ora un salto temporale
e andiamo in Francia,
dove troviamo Vincent Van Gogh
nel 1890
seduto in un campo di grano,
intento a dipingere
quello che sarà considerato
un nuovo progresso figurativo.
Anche in quest'opera
vediamo
una tempesta, figurativamente
e concettualmente diversa
da quella del Giorgione.
Il Giorgione con il quadro rappresenta
una allegoria misteriosa.
Van Gogh, il suo quadro
non rappresenta, è.
E quest'opera è considerata
il punto di non ritorno,
l'opera che anticipò i tempi,
la prima opera di arte contemporanea.
Ovviamente non sono gli unici
ad aver affrontato o rappresentato
una tempesta o uno tsunami,
o un Diluvio Universale,
ma quasi tutti gli artisti che hanno
affrontato questo tema
non lo hanno fatto una volta
raggiunta la maturità artistica,
lo hanno fatto da giovani maturi.
Il Giorgione aveva ventiquattro anni
quando dipinse la tempesta.
Per i non giovani Shakespeare scrisse
la Tempesta a quarantasei anni.
Ma non sono qui per tenere
una lezione di storia dell'arte,
o fare le previsioni del meteo.
Sono qui per condividere
un'osservazione.
Molti di noi durante la nostra giornata
professionale facciamo brainstorming,
cervelli in tempesta.
Sappiamo tutti che è una tecnica creativa
di gruppo, si parte da un problema,
ci si concede
la massima libertà propositiva
senza censure,
alla ricerca di soluzioni e nuove idee.
In gruppo quindi, ma tutto questo
gli artisti lo fanno da soli.
Come? Osservando la quiete,
prima della tempesta.
La loro urgenza creativa
non gli permette di aspettare
che qualcuno
gli sottoponga un problema
per trovare una soluzione,
e tantomeno proporre idee
sulla base di un'esigenza.
Gli artisti anticipano
tempestivamente.
Ma attenzione, tempestività non è sinonimo
di velocità, non significa arrivare primi,
significa arrivare prima, perchè
più veloci andiamo e più tempo perdiamo.
Quest'epoca è caratterizzata dalla
velocità, noi per la velocità
sacrifichiamo la qualità
sotto tutti i suoi aspetti.
Basti pensare al motto di Facebook:
fatto è meglio che perfetto.
Ma è proprio nel come facciamo le cose
che risiede il perché le facciamo.
Certo, cercare la perfezione
o porsi obiettivi irraggiungibili
può essere frustrante,
ma io non mi riferisco a questo.
Mi riferisco a come facevano il pane
le nonne, e al perché lo facevano così,
perchè lo facevano per noi.
E permettetemi, lo facevano sempre
al momento giusto, cioè tempestivamente.
Questo è il sinonimo da ricercare.
Quindi per comprendere meglio
il significato di tempestività,
proviamo ad analizzare
il significato di tempesta,
che cos'è una tempesta.
Una tempesta
è un qualunque stato disturbato
di un corpo celeste. Wow.
Prima al buffet
ne ho incontrati
un paio, di disturbati,
li vedo anche in sala.
Ma come si forma una tempesta?
Una tempesta si sviluppa
intorno alla combinazione
di forze opposte
che producono
vortici acquei e diavoli di sabbia.
Quindi vuol dire che,
prima della tempesta,
c'è calma piatta, quiete, noia.
Tutto questo gli artisti
ce l'hanno dentro.
Le forze opposte, il corpo celeste, i
vortici,i diavoli, il disturbo, il buffet,
e anche la calma piatta, la quiete,
e la noia. Sì, la noia.
Perché vedete, per osservare il mondo
come fanno gli artisti, bisogna avere
una grande capacità di annoiarsi.
Perché solo annoiandosi del mondo si ha
la possibilità di creare il proprio mondo.
Dobbiamo comprendere che non possiamo
coprire tutti i buchi dove ci sarebbe
la noia, soprattutto coi bambini.
Perchè è dalla noia che nasce il gioco.
E credetemi, non c'è niente di più serio
del gioco di un bambino.
E anche dei grandi.
La noia è l'alleato principale
per creare una tempesta.
La noia è il punto preciso tra la realtà
e la fantasia.
Perchè dalle tempeste si fugge
come dalla noia.
Certo, per me è facile parlare di noia,
vengo dalla provincia friulana.
Vi racconto questa:
qualche anno fa, mi trovavo
a Napoli con due amici,
Fabio e Paolone.
Situazione classica.
Parcheggiamo la macchina
vicino al Maschio Angioino,
diamo 10 euro al ragazzo,
intanto che chiediamo
dove possiamo andare a cenare,
si avvicina un po' di gente.
A un certo punto un uomo di mezza età
ci guarda e ci chiede di dove siamo.
Di Udine, rispondiamo noi.
Ah, fa lui.
Ho fatto il militare a Palmanova.
Beh, noi siamo di Codroipo.
Uè, quando volevo annoiarmi
veramente
venivo a Codroipo!
(Risate)
Vedete, noia e tempestività,
uguale una tempesta di risate.
Quindi, questo non vale solo
per gli artisti
o per i parcheggiatori abusivi.
Mi spiego meglio.
C'era una volta un signore annoiato,
che passeggiava perso nei suoi pensieri.
Ad un certo punto
fu attirato da degli schiamazzi
provenienti da un cortile.
Si fermò a vedere
dei bambini giocare a biglie.
Notò che queste sfere,
passando attraverso una pozzanghera,
uscendo lasciavano una riga di fango.
Siamo a Budapest nel 1938,
e quel signore era Laszlo Biro,
l'inventore della penna a sfera.
Un giornalista, al punto preciso tra
la realtà e la fantasia,
può diventare un inventore.
Laurie Anderson è una delle artiste
che stimo di più.
Musicista, pittrice, scrittrice,
artista multimediale, si definisce
semplicemente una narratrice di storia.
Nel 2003 le fu chiesto di entrare
a fare parte al primo programma
all'interno della NASA.
Fu residente alla NASA per due anni.
Le venne chiesto di vivere a stretto
contatto con gli scienziati.
Intervistata alla fine
di questa esperienza dichiarò:
"Programmi come questo
dovrebbero essere ovunque.
Un'artista vede le cose
da un punto di vista
unico e solitario,
come gli astronauti."
Anche lei affronterà
il tema della tempesta.
Vi leggo un estratto dalla sua canzone:
"La tempesta continua a soffiare l'angelo
indietro, nel futuro.
E questa tempesta è chiamata progresso".
Andy Warhol disse che in futuro ognuno
di noi al mondo sarà famoso per 15 minuti.
Beh, qua me ne hanno dati solo otto,
per cui vado a concludere.
Ogni volta che studio gli artisti capisco
che la tempesta ha un grande
lato positivo, e cioè il nuovo.
E il nuovo ha bisogno di sostenitori.
Deciderete da soli come affrontare questa
tempesta moderna che vi attende.
E sarà una cosa bellissima
se la saprete affrontare
con la giusta dose di noia.
Adesso vi chiederete cosa c'entra
il Giorgione con la NASA.
Beh, ditemelo voi.
Io speravo solo di annoiarvi veramente.
Grazie.
(Applausi)